so when we accepted the award
my phone just started buzzing in my
pocket and i was trying to ignore it and
i'm sure everyone was saying
congratulations so it was the wrong idea
to have my phone in my pocket on stage
and i'll send everyone messages later my
manager will take care of it hopefully
when i got up there i'm thinking oh my
god i cannot forget anyone to thank i
might have forgotten to thank a couple
people but i looked at the sea of faces
all these actors and then i saw meryl
i'm like okay fine and then
those are the people
who are actors just like us
and to be able to be included you know
amongst our peers it's about time it's
about time and they all saw us
there are plenty of pretty voices with
nothing to say
do you have something to say for me this
is a dream come true i just
came to this country
uh looking for an opportunity and i feel
the same as these guys i feel that
now finally
the community is
seeing me
so uh
i'm really really thankful and um
especially uh that i can give a voice to
all latino actors that i are waiting for
an opportunity you know they always
portray latinos in a very uh
different way on
hollywood so the fact that right now i'm
doing a character it has nothing to do
with a
criminal or a
gang member it's very important for me
i can't stay with you for the rest of my
life
and then i saw meryl streep again i had
to
i i had to give her a shout out i mean
we know each other but i just
it was just extra something extra
because she was sitting in the room and
so many other actors out there i mean um
oh javier bardem excuse me looking at me
came right up afterwards and gave us the
biggest hug and
lent his support and that's that's a
nice feeling really